kaum eine runde geht wir machen street
view und es hat geklappt
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen hier zu einer
weiteren folge der minecraft facts
wollte ich hier an einem freitag
und ich würde eigentlich schon sagen ich
will hier gar nicht lange um heißen brei
reden ich hab mir blieb ja 56
rausgesucht ich würde mich freuen wenn
bis zum ende dran bleibt weiter in dem
video menge arbeit steckt ich kann jetzt
noch viel mehr scheiße labern aber wir
fangen einfach an effekt nummer eins
wurde mir zugesendet von 870 und tableau
meine ich und zwar hat er mir etwas über
orchideen beziehungsweise texturen
allgemeine minecraft gesendet ich weiß
nicht ob er dieses etwas meint was
ähnliche fragen wollte das recht
kompliziert geschrieben ist aber schaut
euch mal diesem stengel von der orchidee
jetzt beispielsweise mehr geht er so ein
bisschen nach links das heißt diese
blume ist quasi so ein bisschen geneigt
wenn ich jetzt allerdings mal hierhin
gehe
seht ihr die geht auch nach links so ein
bisschen wenn ich mal hier schau geht
die auch nach links und wenn ich mal
hierhin schau geht die auch nach links
das ist zwar so wenn ich von oben drauf
schaut klar es sind alles nur so sachen
so quasi so soll wie so ein
pappaufsteller aber trotzdem ist beim
pappaufsteller ist nicht so dass das
ganze dann in alle richtungen so nach
links geht das heißt es ist eine
optische täuschung falls man denkt dass
dieses ding aus jeder richtung irgendwie
das ist jetzt nach da zeigt quasi die
blume
aber wenn ich so sauer dass die blume
quasi in diese richtung gebogen ist weil
eigentlich müsste es ja wenn wir mal von
dieser situation als richtig ausgehen
müsste mehr in diese richtung gebogen
sein das heißt dementsprechend der
irgendwie dann ich sage mal so in etwa
so müsste die blumen aussehen das heißt
allerdings wenn ich von hier drauf gucke
müsste es dann auch in die richtung
gehen hier geht es dann allerdings
wieder nach links also wieder nach da
das ist ein bisschen crazy ein weiteres
beispiel kann man eigentlich ganz cool
an diesen birken setzen erkennen und
zwar auf der linken seite seht ihr das
in diese beiden hören und hier sind die
beiden niedrigeren wenn ich jetzt aber
mal hier rumlaufen seht ihr schon so
bald ich über diese schwelle gehe dieses
blattes erst so und jetzt wenn ich
weiter gehe ist dann auf einmal so groß
ich finde daran kann man es eigentlich
so am besten ecken also so seht ihr
schon hier verändert sich die textur
dann auf einmal ein stückchen weiter
dann ist das wieder so klein
und wenn ich dann hier lang gehe dann
ist das wieder so groß verstehen was ich
meine das ist ein bisschen
während bei diesen texturen da achtet
man so gar nicht drauf aber es ist auf
jeden fall ganz interessant das ist ja
beim auffällt und da finde ich könnte
man die texte auf jeder seite an das mal
gestalten nicht dass ich jetzt immer
wieder wiederholt man merkt es zwar
nicht aber es liegt schon so ein
bisschen crazy aus wenn man so also ob
das mal so einfach hier so drumherum
geht das sieht schon ein bisschen krank
aus und das perfekt nummer eins und ich
hab voll an darüber geredet grad ins
halt immer scheiße wehrleute die
kommentare schreiben
der weg war doch voll blöd und voll
simpel das liegt doch da und daran und
ich denke einfach nur ihr habt falsch
falsch verstanden ich wollte das gar
nicht so zeigen wie es klar ist sondern
was anderes daran zeigen deswegen das
verstehen manchmal leute falsch aber
naja ich hoffe ich konnte euch erklären
jetzt komplett perfekt numero zwei ihr
kennt ja alle diesem barrier blog den
ich gerade im inventar ab den bekommt
man über diesen command / oder euren in
dem namen berri und dann kann man ihn
einfach hinsetzen dann entscheidet er so
ein rotes kreuz oder wenn ich
beispielsweise einfach mal zerstöre
seht ihr jeden moment wird auch dieses
kreuze verschwinden soll da ist es weg
und das ist einfach so einen blog da
kann man beispielsweise in der tollen
job einfach mal so die sind dann
natürlich dass dann keine kreuze drin
dann läuft man dann einfach rüber und
dann sind da so unsichtbare blöcke so
zum springen oder so beispielsweise
allerdings wenn ihr darauf achtet ich
lasse jetzt mal nur einen barrier hier
stehen die restlichen müssten endlich im
moment verschwinden genau da sind weg
der jetzt einfach ein glas blog hier
neben und zwar seht ihr jetzt schon wenn
ich hier beispielsweise den terrier
einfach so stehen haben und dich ein
wenig weg fliege seht ihr schon der
barrier verschwindet extrem schnell und
zwar schon aus einer gewissen entfernung
wenn ich beispielsweise jetzt noch ein
bisschen soll jetzt ist er verschwunden
aus dieser entfernung und wenn ich jetzt
mal wieder dahin fliege seht ihr moment
da ist nämlich wieder und wenn ich jetzt
wieder ein bisschen weg fliege dann
sieht man ihn auf jeden fall nicht mehr
da steht nämlich im minecraft wirklich
und zwar das barriere zeichen im block
verschwindet wenn man sich zu weit davon
entfernt ist es nicht als block textor
realisiert sondern als riesiger partikel
in minecraft ist ja einfach wenn man
sich sonnen unsichtbarkeit beispiels
trank beispielsweise mal nimmt oder ich
unter anderem auch einfach mal jetzt
etwas anzünden das heißt ich nehme jetzt
mal ein maverick und ein feuerzeug so
ich hab jetzt da das feuer da sind die
feuer partikel und da dieser barry ja
nicht als block angesehen sondern als
riesiger partikel müsste es jetzt auf
der gleichen entfernung verschwinden so
wie diese feuer animation die feuer
animation sieht man jetzt schon nicht
mehr
und jetzt sieht man auch nicht mehr dass
berry hat man sieht aber dass meine welt
immer mehr an bringt aber wenn ich jetzt
meine heranfliegen
seht ihr jeden moment wieder das barrier
und auch das feuer und zwar jetzt guckt
dass die feiert expo wieder unter das
barrier also der barrier wird quasi als
einfach nicht als block angesehen wo ich
zwar drauf
kann uns so aber die textur wird als
partikel angesehen und es ist gerade
nacht und ich befinde mich hier im game
mode 0 einfach weil der nächste fact
damit zu tun hat und zwar schreibt mir
ja sie wenn man bei nacht aus großer
höhe springt und darunter ein bett steht
und sich vor dem aufprall schlafen legt
bekommt man erst bei dem aufwachen den
schaden
ich habe einfach eine night vision
genommen damit nicht allzu dunkel ist
über 45 minuten oder so um den dreh und
ich hoffe ich treffe das bett ich habe
max sonderleiter gemacht und zwar die
sache ist ich springe jetzt runter und
kriege ja eigentlich aus dieser höhe ich
weiß nicht welcher höhe ist das so sechs
blöcke fünf sechs blöcke oder so wie ich
nur zwei drei herzen schaden oder so
oder vier keine ahnung und wenn ich ins
bett springen quasi lege ich mich erst
schlafen und danach bekomme ich den fall
schaden also nicht wenn ich im bett
liege ich hoffe ich schaffe das jetzt so
ich liege jetzt im bett und wenn ich
jetzt auf stil bekomme ich jetzt den
fall schaden achtet mal darauf und jetzt
habe ich erst den fall schaden bekommen
ok in einer im herzen war schon ganz
frisch aber wenn wir jetzt
beispielsweise mal einfach wieder times
at night ein geben könnt ihr euch das
noch mal kurz anschauen
ich springe von hier aus dem bett auf
dem bett ich springe von hier aus der
höhe lege mich im bett jetzt habe ich
schon den fall schaden bekommen weil ich
nicht rechtzeitig rechts gedrückt habe
also müsste wirklich die ganzen
rechtsweg drücken und dann bekommt ihr
den fall schaden auf jeden fall erst
wenn die aufgewacht seid ihr habt ja
vorher schon gesehen am anfang ganz
geklappt und auch kaum eine runde geht
wir machen street view und es hat
geklappt es hat geklappt meine lieben
freunde und ihr seht wenn ich jetzt auf
stehe ich bekomme jetzt erst den fall
schaden das war auf jeden fall fügte
numero drei da wollen wir uns eine von
ja sie
ja danke schön so freunde fact nummero 4
wurde mir zugesendet von dazu und zwar
schreibt der halo conny du kennst doch
sicher letztlich sicher liegt dass ich
tief mit push ups wo man leder von einer
kuh bekommen muss falls du dieses noch
nicht erreicht hast und ein pferd tötest
welches leder fall lässt erhältst du
dass ich tief mit auch das ist extrem
komisch und zwar bei der map accepted
minecraft 2 zusammen mit komme valukas
ja so der jo ich brauche gar keine
sbornaja war hier sind die pferde
jedenfalls war es da so wenn man einen
diamanten findet kann man ihnen einfach
dem anderen spieler zu werden zu werfen
dann hat er natürlich auch das archiv
mit allerdings bei diesen pferden es ist
nicht so dass es uns zu werfen geht von
einem item dass man das nicht mitbekommt
sondern es geht darum wenn dich jemand
mit ihr wäre hier das nächste tief mit
kippa harvest sammelte das ist nämlich
schon mal richtig und zwar muss man
leder bekommen aber da allerdings heißt
es ich bin immer noch kauftipp also kuh
schubser auf deutsch ich hab das einfach
immer auf englisch weil ich finde ein
spieler muss auf englisch sein das
komische daran ist einfach dass man es
halt nur bekommen wenn man auch leser
wirklich zu geworfen bekommt oder wenn
ich jetzt beispielsweise einfach ein
pferd das hat jetzt kein leder fallen
lassen dass hier katheder verlassen und
wenn ich jetzt hin laufen bekomme ich
trotzdem dass ich tief mit kipper was er
irgendwie total sinnlos ist weil ich ja
eigentlich ein pferd getötet habe also
pferde schubser oder so
das heißt hier meine appellieren an
mojang bietet ändert doch dieses
achievement einfach in letter pharma
oder irgendwie leder fetish ist oder
keine ahnung was irgendwas was sinn
ergibt aber auf jeden fall nicht mehr
kippen weil das ergibt überhaupt keinen
sinn so freunde der fünfte fake wurde
mir zugesendet von nora j und zwar oder
nur adrette mikula an hey luca ich habe
herausgefunden dass wenn ein
deaktivierte sneijder portal von einem
blitz getroffen wird es aktiviert wird
und wenn ein aktiviert des net a porter
von einem blitz getroffen wird es
deaktiviert wir den effekt hat sie noch
nie gesehen deswegen hat sie sich jeder
tag komme ich schicke dir einfach mal
den luca zu und zwar befinde ich mich
gerade hier irgendwo um den nullpunkt um
einfach damit ich nicht so viel eingeben
muss weil ich vor hinweise koordinaten
waren die hatten zwar auch tausende und
abertausende koordination so freundlich
habe jetzt hier diesen obsidian rahmen
erst mal gebauten portal ist es ja noch
nicht und zwar was mir die
liebe person die mit diesem weg zu
gesendet hat so ein bisschen schwer
erklärt hat und zwar wie ist das jetzt
genau mit dem aktivieren und
deaktivieren also dieses portal ist
jetzt natürlich deaktiviert das heißt
wenn da ein blitz reingeschossen wird
wird es aktiviert aber wenn es aktiviert
wäre dann könnte ein blitz wieder
deaktivieren das heißt ich stelle mich
jetzt einfach mal ins portal gebe
schrägstrich sammeln und leerzeichen
lightning bolt ein und ihr seht schon
downloading teurer weil das portal ich
stand ja im portal der blitzer das
portal angeschossen und ich komme direkt
in den neckar und wenn wir jetzt mal
anschauen
ok ich befinde mich hier ich mache es
beispielsweise einfach das portal kaputt
und ihr seht schon ich bin bei position
xyz 261 -6 das heißt wenn jetzt ein gebe
zusammen lightning bolt 261 und -6 dann
seht ihr schon ich habe das portal nicht
getroffen ich gebe jetzt mal einfach - 7
1 und dann seht ihr schon der blitz hat
das portal angeschossen ihr könnt auch
wieder sehen wenn ich das gleiche jetzt
noch mal ein gebe seht ihr das portal
wieder aus geschossen und damit kann ich
quasi jetzt die ganze zeit
alles mögliche machen uns nur
anschließen oder dann mache ich wieder
aus oder irgendwas anderes optimaler
freundin das war auf jeden fall facto
nummer 35
coaching und ich würde sagen das war's
dann auch schon von dieser folge der
minecraft facts hier aus dem netter wenn
es euch gefallen hat würde ich mich
definitiv über eine bewertung freuen
dass immer eine menge menge arbeit ist
die städte zu bearbeiten effects list
freunde nicht über sex formular das sind
33.000 fragen und commands reingekommen
und ich krieg da keinen überblick mehr
ich möchte einfach bitte freuen wenn ihr
einen effekt hat schreibt ihn in die
kommentare hier oder wenn ihr mir schon
um das formular zugesendet habt dann
noch mal in die kommentare schreiben
oder wenn ihr mir schon mal per mail
zugesendet habe dann auch hier in die
kommentare schreiben weil ich mach das
jetzt genauso über den kräftigen in
denen da ist es nämlich richtig cool
wenn die community in den kommentaren
darüber diskutiert und wenn ich ein fake
zugesendet bekommen über das formular
dann denkt man von ok
der geht nicht aber wenn er in den
kommentaren steht kann ich noch bei den
kommentaren puck untersagen dann
eventuell leute hey du hast ein bisschen
was falsch erklärt das geht so und so
und dann kriegt diese person hat den
kommentar weil sie es dann richtig
erklärt und ein wenig beide und so ich
denke ihr wisst was ich meine
das heißt wenn effekt wird einfach in
die kommentare schreiben spam mir die
kommentare von endeffekt würde ich mich
sehr darüber freuen und dann sehen wir
uns in einem nächsten video wieder